.
>> Bill: RICH EDSON IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., THANK YOU.
>> Dana: LET'S BRING IN FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE WHOSE
BOOK "SO HELP ME GOD"  IS
AVAILABLE NOW.
LOTS OF NEWS ON THIS MONDAY
MORNING.
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
WE JUST DID A STORY, AN
INTERVIEW WITH A GENTLEMAN WHOSE
-- SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDER
FROM AFGHANISTAN, HIS BROTHER
WAS TRAINED BY US TO BE AN ELITE
FORCES COMMANDO.
HE IS BEING HELD IN A PRICE ON
MAKING IT THROUGH THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
HE WOULD LIKE TO TELL PRESIDENT
BIDEN THIS, HIS BROTHER.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT COME TO THE
BORDERS WITHOUT ANY VETTING,
THEY ARE BEING RELEASED.
BUT MY BROTHER COMES WITH A
BACKGROUND, A CLEAR BACKGROUND.
HE DESERVES RECOGNITION FOR HIS
SERVICE, NOT TO BE IN PRISON AND
NOT TO BE TORTURED BY A COUNTRY
THAT HE STOOD ALONGSIDE.
>> Dana: WONDER WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS.
YOU TAKE THE AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL CHAOS, THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE AT THE BORDER, IT
IS A CONFLUENCE OF INEPTITUDE
RESULTING IN THIS MAN BEING IN
PRISON.
>> IT IS A CONFLUENCE OF
INEPTITUDE.
TO THINK ABOUT A HEROIC AFGHAN
SOLDIER WHO RISKED HIS AND HIS
FAMILY'S LIFE TO STAND WITH OUR
SOLDIERS AND HAVING TO GO TO
SOUTH AMERICA TO JOIN THE
MASSIVE MOVEMENT NORTH OF THE
BORDER AND HE IS THE ONE WE PUT
IN JAIL WHEN HE CROSSES THE
BORDER.
IT REALLY IS EXTRAORDINARY.
I HOPE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
WATCHING AND MOVES QUICKLY TO
REMEDY THAT SITUATION WITH HIM.
WE OWE A DEBT OF HONOR AND
GRATITUDE TO EVERY ONE OF THE
AFGHAN SOLDIERS THAT STOOD WITH
THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
FOUGHT IN AFGHANISTAN ON OUR
BEHALF OVER THOSE 20 YEARS.
LET ME TELL YOU, I WAS DOWN TO
THE BORDER TWICE OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND THE MOST JARRING THING
THAT I HEARD MORE THAN NINE
MONTHS AGO WAS THAT THE CARTELS
ARE IN OPERATIONAL CONTROL OF
OUR BORDER TODAY.
LITERALLY I STOOD IN COCHISE
COUNTY AT A SECTION OF THE
BORDER WHERE ON DAY ONE
PRESIDENT BIDEN ENDED
CONSTRUCTION OF THE BORDER WALL
AND SO YOU SEE ALL THESE GIRDERS
LAID OUT IN THE SUN SHINE
RUSTING IN THE SUNSHINE.
100 YARDS ACROSS THE BORDER YOU
COULD SEE A LOOKOUT NEST OF THE
CARTELS.
THEY DECIDE WHO COMES IN AND THE
CRISIS IN EL PASO THIS WEEK
TELLS YOU ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW.
>> Bill: OTHER PEOPLE SEE THAT.
WHY THE REST OF THE MEDIA HASN'T
BEEN REPORTING ON THIS UNTIL THE
LAST WEEK.
WHEN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CAME IN THERE WAS THINKING THEY
WANTED TO DO THE OPPOSITE OF YOU
AND FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP DID.
AND MAYBE IT WAS YOU WON'T DO
DACA AND WE'LL ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN OR THE BORDER POLICIES OF
SEPARATING FAMILIES SO WE'LL DO
THE OPPOSITE OF THAT.
CAN YOU HELP US UNDERSTAND WHY
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN SO
-- YOU COULD CALL IT INEPT OR
YOU COULD CALL IT A REFUSAL TO
DO SOMETHING.
>> I DON'T CALL IT INEPT.
IT IS OPERATING EXACTLY AS THOSE
THAT ADVOCATE OPEN BORDERS WANT
IT TO OPERATE.
WE ENDED ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND
ASYLUM ABUSE BY 90% UNDER A
COMBINATION OF A BORDER WALL,
INTERNAL ENFORCEMENT, THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY THAT I
NEGOTIATED ON THE PRESIDENT'S
BEHALF WITH MEXICAN OFFICIALS,
AND TITLE 42 THAT WE PUT INTO
EFFECT IN THOSE EARLY DAYS OF
THE COVID PANDEMIC.
THE COMBINATION OF THOSE THINGS
ENDED THE CRISIS AT OUR BORDER
BUT WHEN JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE
AND THE OPEN BORDERS CROWD WAS
IN THE SADDLE IN CONGRESS AND
WHITE HOUSE, THEY GOT RID OF ALL
OF THAT AND THE CRISIS HAPPENED.
>> Bill: HOW DID THEY BENEFIT
FROM OPEN BORDERS?
>> I WOULD LEAVE THAT -- I DON'T
LIKE SPECULATING ON PEOPLE'S
MOTIVES.
I'M SOMEBODY BELIEVES THAT A
NATION WITHOUT BORDERS IS NOT A
NATION.
MY HOPE IS SEEING 15,000 PEOPLE
COME IN IN A SINGLE WEEK IN EL
PASO.
HAVING THE DEMOCRAT MAYOR OF EL
PASO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY MIGHT JUST JAR THIS
ADMINISTRATION INTO HOLDING OFF
ON UNDOING TITLE 42, WHICH WAS
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE UNDER OUR
ADMINISTRATION.
AND FOR HEAVENS SAKES THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY WAS JUST COMMON
SENSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE IT CLEAR
THERE WOULD BE CONSEQUENCES IF
MEXICO DID NOT STEP UP AND AGREE
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO WAIT IN
MEXICO WHEN THEY APPLIED FOR
ASYLUM.
WE STOOD FIRM AND WE
ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
WE CAN SECURE OUR BORDER AND END
THIS CRISIS WITH GOOD
LEADERSHIP.
>> Dana: THE ONE THING THEY'RE
FOCUSED ON IS THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE, THEY SAY, SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO CHARGE PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HERE IS ADAM SCHIFF, THE
DEMOCRAT FROM CALIFORNIA, ON
THAT.
>> I THINK THAT THE EVIDENCE THE
THERE THAT DONALD TRUMP
COMMITTED CRIMINAL OFFENSES IN
CONNECTION WITH HIS EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
VIEWING IT AS A FORMER
PROSECUTOR, I THINK THERE IS
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO CHARGE
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: THERE HAS BEEN A
BUILD-UP TO THIS MOMENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF IT?
>> WELL, I'VE SAID MANY TIMES
HAVING LIVED THROUGH THAT DAY AT
THE CAPITOL, DANA.
JANUARY 6TH WAS A TRAGIC DAY.
BUT THANKS TO THE COURAGE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE VIOLENCE WAS
QUELLED AND FINISHED OUR WORK
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION THE SAME
DAY.
BUT I MUST TELL YOU FROM EARLY
ON I HAVE BEEN DISAPPOINTED IN
THE PARTISAN NATURE OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
TO HAVE A COMMITTEE THAT WAS
LITERALLY APPOINTED IN ITS
ENTIRETY BY THE DEMOCRAT SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE REALLY VIOLATES THE
HISTORY AND TRADITION OF THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES.
YOU MAY NOT REMEMBER IN 2007, I
WAS THE RANKING MEMBER ON A
SELECT COMMITTEE THAT LOOKED
INTO VOTING IRREGULARITIES.
WE HAD PROPER REPRESENTATION OF
ALL POLITICAL PARTIES AND THEY
WERE ALL ALLOWED TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF WITNESSES.
WE PRODUCED A REPORT AT THE END.
AND THIS SELECT COMMITTEE FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING HAS
REPRESENTED KIND OF A PARTISAN
TAINT THAT I THINK IT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY SO FEW AMERICANS
ARE PAYING MUCH ATTENTION TO
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TODAY OR TO THE
RESULTS OR RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
>> Bill: LET ME JUST -- IF YOU
FEEL THAT WAY AND ANSWERED IT
THAT WAY YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT
SHOULD BE A CRIMINAL CASE THAT
SHOULD BE REFERRED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> I WROTE THIS IN MY BOOK HOW
MANY TIMES ADAM SCHIFF SAID THAT
THERE WAS EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA, 2 1/2 YEARS WE
LISTENED TO ADAM SCHIFF TALK
ABOUT EVIDENCE THAT HE HAD SEEN
THAT WAS NEVER THERE.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS
POINT.
CONGRESS HAS NO FORMAL ROLE IN
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DECISIONS.
THEY CAN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TODAY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S DECISION ABOUT
BRINGING CHARGES IN THE FUTURE,
I WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BRING CHARGES AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T -- LOOK, AS I WROTE IN
MY BOOK, I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
ACTIONS AND WORDS ON JANUARY 6TH
WERE RECKLESS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT IT IS
CRIMINAL TO TAKE BAD ADVICE FROM
LAWYERS AND SO I HOPE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS CAREFUL.
>> Dana: WE'LL SEE ON THAT.
>> I WANT TO SAY I HOPE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT UNDERSTANDS
THE MAGNITUDE AND THE VERY IDEA
OF INDICTING A FORMER PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE TERRIBLY
DIVISIVE IN THE COUNTRY AT A
TIME WHEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT TO SEE US HEAL.
AT THIS TIME OF YEAR WE'RE ALL
THINKING ABOUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS IN OUR LIVES,
OUR FAITH, FAMILY AND MY HOPE IS
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
THINK VERY CAREFULLY.
>> Dana: YOUR WHOLE FAMILY WILL
BE TOGETHER.
ALL THE FAMILY IS GETTING
TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THREE YEARS AND THAT'S VERY
EXCITING.
YOU WROTE THE BOOK, WE HAVE READ
THAT YOU ARE CONSIDERING YOUR
FUTURE POLITICAL.
THIS HEADLINE TODAY IN
"POLITICO."
PENCE HAS A HUGE PROBLEM.
STRUGGLING TO FIND HIS PATH BACK
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WOULD YOU MAKE A DECISION AFTER
THE HOLIDAYS IF YOU WOULD GET IN
FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
IF NOT THE PRESIDENCY WOULD YOU
BE OPEN TO RUNNING IN THE SENATE
SEAT IN INDIANA?
>> I TELL YOU, I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING IN CONGRESS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
GOVERNOR OF INDIANA AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
MY FAMILY IS GOING THE TAKE TIME
OVER THIS HOLIDAY SEASON WHEN
WE'RE ALL TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THREE YEARS TO GIVE
PRAYERFUL CONSIDERATION TO WHERE
WE MIGHT NEXT STEP FORWARD TO
SERVE OUR COUNTRY.
BUT FOR US IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT A
CALLING.
IF YOU READ MY BOOK, DANA, YOU
WILL FIND EARLY IN MY POLITICAL
CAREER I ALLOWED MY AMBITION TO
GET AHEAD OF MY CHRISTIAN FAITH,
WHAT I THOUGHT MY FAITH REQUIRED
OF ME IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE.
BUT THE LAST 20 YEARS IT HAS
BEEN ABOUT A CALLING AND ABOUT
TRYING TO RESPOND TO THAT CALL.
SO WE ARE GOING TO LISTEN TO ONE
ANOTHER, PRAY AND CONTINUE TO
LISTEN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND SOMETIME IN THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT YEAR WE'LL BE ABLE TO
DISCERN THAT AND --
>> Dana: IS IT A POSSIBILITY
SNOW
>> I SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE FOR FOUR YEARS.
I WOULD TELL YOU THE
EXTRAORDINARY EXPERIENCES WE
HAVE HAD IN OUR LIFE, THE
RESPONSE THAT WE'VE GOTTEN TO
TELLING OUR STORY IN MY BOOK "SO
HELP ME GOD"  AND ENCOURAGEMENT
AROUND THE COUNTRY HAS US
THINKING OF ONE MORE SEASON OF
SERVICE.
THAT'S THE ONE WE'RE FOCUSED ON.
>> Bill: WE'LL PUT YOU DOWN AS A
MAYBE.
>> Dana: I TOOK IT AS A NO.
YES FOR THE POSSIBLE WHITE HOUSE
RUN BUT A NO FOR THE SENATE RUN.
>> I THINK IF WE WERE EVER TO
STEP FORWARD TO SERVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, IT WOULD BE TO
TAKE ALL THE EXPERIENCE WE'VE
HAD AND RUN FOR NATIONAL OFFICE
AND -- BUT I'M HUMBLED TO BE
ASKED.
SOMEBODY ASKED ME THE OTHER DAY
IF I THOUGHT ABOUT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND I THOUGHT NO MORE
OR NO LESS THAN ANY OTHER KID
THAT GREW